I saw that Louis just tweeted that he
had to change his phone number he's
getting so many awful messages what was
going on you know I think I think they
love him a lot now everyone wants to
channel the book to us so I can
understand it Kofi is part of one of the
most famous boy bands in the world a lot
of her hard for you I think Louis treats
me so well
I think he's got his own job I have mine
too so it's it I I can understand where
he's coming from what they think
definitely helps a lot and he's
wonderful so I understand the appeal
from all the other girls I love seeing
all the photos of you with hanging out
with baby Freddie what is that like for
you he's wonderful
I think Louie and Breanna have done a
great job raising him and he's one of
the most special little boys
so they've done a great job and he's
stunning I mean they've got beautiful
parents so hard to argue with is he
talking at all yet not quite yet he's
getting there I think he's making lots
of noises though oh you're so young but
do you baby fever at all not quite yet I
think there's a lot that I want to do I
have so much respect for Breanna for
everything that she's that she's doing I
think she's a wonderful mother where do
you see you and Louie headed you feel
like a ring is in the future at all I
think right now we're young and we're
enjoying each other's company and he's
he's been so good to me and I care about
him a lot